and we do start with breaking news a  huge fire just west of the strip near  the palms resort it was a warehouse fire  near arville and flamingo clark county  fire says this started at about 8 30  this morning on bertsos drive you may  have actually seen the smoke filling the  sky was there for some time  edwin phillips owns an auto body shop  nearby he says it's not the first time  that buildings caught fire  buildings and vacants as i moved in here  five years ago and there's homeless  people in and out of it all the time  this is the second fire in two days in  this building  along with two other fires that happened  across the street  certainly have been some issues in that  area the fire is basically out now no  reports so far of any injuries  now